اغنى اغنياء العالم فمع الخسائر التي
تتعرض لها الاسهم التقنيه ستطاع رجل اعمال
الفرنسي برنار اخنوط تربوا على عرش اغنى
رجل بالعالم بفروه بلغت 171 مليار دولار
في المقابل تراجع الثروه توماس الى 1964
مليار دولار اغنوه ورئيس مجلس اداره
مجموعه البي ام اتش ويمتلك وعائلته 48% من
اسهم مجموعه الرائده في مجال السلع
الفاخره بالعالم والتي تملك 75 علامه
تجاريه مختلفه واشهرهم على الاطراف
لديهم اكثر من 5000 500 متجر حول العالم
سجلت قيمتها السوقيه 388 مليار دولار
وبلغت مبيعاتها في سنه 20 21 الى 68 مليار
دولار
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
راينا ملك التقنيه الى الماسك يفقد مركزك
اغنى رجل في العالم لصالح ملك العلامات
الفاخره الفرنسي صاحب ايامك
اصلا كنا عم نحكي عن لبنان
شخصيتين الى الماسك كثير ظاهر للعالم كثير
بيحكي كتير بياثر حتى على يعني مشاعر
المستثمرين كان عم نحكي على شركه
نوعا ما في عديد من العوامل هذا الشيء اول
شيء قطعتك للوجه بيتاثر بالنظر المستقبل
من بدايه العام اكثر من 43% بالوقت اللي
عم بشوف قطاع يمكن اللاكجري او همم فاخر
عن السيارات الفاخره المجوهرات
البعد كان عم يرتفعوا عم نشوف الاسهم كمان
مرتفعه في هذا القطاع
جديده طبعا ولكن هذا السبب اللي بنشوف طيب
يعني هذا بالنسبه طب كيف يعني تغير
الثقافه المستهلك اليوم او انها تطورت
وصارت بس ميال القطعه الفاخره نحن نمر في
زمن اصلا فيه ازمات اقتصاديه تضخم ورفع
سعر الفائده وتدهور عملات مشان هيك بدنا
نشوف المستهلك اللي يمكن كل ساعه عم
يستهدفه اذا عم يحكي لنا احنا مثلا كان
حتى همم خلال فتره كوفد وهي السيول
العاليه بالنسبه خلت العديد من اسهم
التكنولوجيا ترتفع اللي احنا كنا قاعدين
بيوتنا كنا بحاجه لان ايمن انه
التكنولوجيا لازم تتطور يمكن عم نحكي على
التواصل عن بعض عن كل شيء
بالوقت الحالي مع السيول المرتفعه مع
ارتفاع الدولار في وجه العملات الاخرى اذا
بدنا نحكي اليورو زي ما نحكي عن الباونت
خلت كل يمكن هالطبقه ان نعتبره ال- ال-
اعلى من المتوسطه والغنيه تكون عم تتوجه
اكثر لتكون عم تشتري هذه الامور اولا سعره
باليورو او بالباوند كان عم يتراجع لان
شكلها عم بشوف يمكن بفكره العامه او المود
العامله هذه الجانيريشن بتوقعوا اكثر انه
يكونوا عن السهلكه على الاسس الفاخره بسبب
بتلاحظ السوشيال ميديا وكلها الامور